so WebMD says I have colitis turns out
when I lost all that weight I thought I
was getting healthy but actually be sick
so now I can't have milk ice cream
she can't have yogurt Baron yeah exactly
Darren can't have it so Chrissy made me
a dairy-free dinner last night it was
actually pretty good honestly every day
I wake up I'm so thankful laughs when
are you gonna settle down man can you
help us settle a bit sure excuse me
we're talking move it along
Thanks seriously man when are you gonna
settle down it's amazing yeah Tim I do
want to meet somebody then what is
stopping you hey I like your shirt that
color looks great on you oh so you just
interrupt people say your whole gig
either up folks we don't know who you
are
later dude seriously why are you not
settling down because you Tim is
impossible to beat girls around you okay
that's insane oh yeah sure okay I'm
insane man suit yourself man
give me his bike he's right what he
isn't saying I'm just a figment of his
imagination oh man
[Music]
yeah